la chronique de l'écho comme chaque
jeudi clair bonsoir deux invités sur ce
plateau bonsoir deux invités oui donc
deux invités qui nous viennent de
l'enseigne McDonald pour nous parler de
la journée des métiers mais auparavant
on va commencer par l'outlet de luxe one
nation qui sont construit aux clés sous-
boois on a déjà parlé de ce centre
commercial sur TVFI 78 à l'époque on
évqué la concurrence avec Carré privé
ouest un autre projet d' hl de luxe à
Montini c'est-à-dire à quelques
kilomètres de là vous allez le voir pour
les initiateurs du projet one nation
Paris qui ont annoncé ce matin la date
de l'ouverture ce problème n'existe
plus au clés sous-bois l'outlette de
luxe one nation sort peu à peu de terre
la date d'ouverture vient d'être
annoncée ce sera le 20 novembre le
concept rassemblé des marques de luxe
qui proposeront leur collection de
l'année précédente à prix cassé jusqu'à
70 % de réduction pendant les soldes 112
marques se partageront les 24000 m car
de surface commercial
et cela représente évidemment pour le
département des créations d'emploi
aujourd'hui on a identifié un besoin
d'environ 800 postes constitués de
responsabl de boutique d'adjoint et de
conseiller de vente aujourd'hui nous
avons mis en place une cVTech sur le
site advantil et bientôt sur le site one
nation sur lequel donc les candidats
sont à même de déposer à la fois leur CV
et leur
candidature un partenariat a également
été lancé avec la mairie Pôle emploi et
un organisme de formation un complexe de
mode et de luxe qui devrait rapporter
selon les développeurs 270 millions de
chiffres d'affaires d'ici 5 ans et pour
assurer une certaine affluence des
navettes achemineront les potentiels
acheteurs en provenance de Paris one
nation compte également sur les 20
millions de visiteurs annuels de la zone
commerciale de grand plaisir pour les
initiateurs du projet tout est lancé
alors leur concurrents direct carré
privé West à Montini ne leur fait pas
peur
évidemment on a beaucoup de respect pour
pour amerson beaucoup de de respect pour
la ville de
Montini il nous semble on le dit depuis
depuis quelques temps que les
fondamentaux pour le un magasin de de
vraiment orienté mode et luxe ne sont
pas ne sont pas présents malheureusement
sur Sky West avec 107 millions d'euros
investis dans ce projet toute
concurrence serait effectivement malvenu
pour rappel le projet carré privé West
devrait compter 80 boutiques et le
groupe amerson qui gère carré privé West
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur notre
antenne un communiqué de presse à
cependant été édité au cours de la
journée il y est question de la
signature de deux enseignes de luxe
italienne qui rejoindraient le centre la
date de fin 2014 pour l'ouverture est
aussi mentionnée pas d'autres éléments
ni sur le début réel du chantier ni sur
son déroulement